what's going on guys this is Rob and for
the last two or three weeks I have been
scouring the web to get as much of the
actual confirmed information about
secret wars that I possibly can to bring
it to you guys and again this is
actually gonna be pretty helpful for us
because what it's going to do is this
basic going to give us this outline of
sorts for the events that are coming up
with regards of suger Wars and we're
going to try to do the same thing with
DC's convergence I'm going to try to go
through and see if I can't find as much
information as I possibly can about
convergence so I can bring you a video
very similar to this one so the first
one is called dystopia and dystopia is
based on a future imperfect now future
imperfect was a story where the
Incredible Hulk was the last surviving
member last surviving super hero among
after after what appeared to have been
basically a nuclear war or a nuclear
bombardment that are broken out in the
world which pretty much eliminated
almost all life now there was still a
group of humans left but these humans
lived under an iron fist
of the future version of The Incredible
Hulk who was referred to as maestro but
what these rebels had done is they had
basically jumped back into the past
using doctor dooms time platform and
they had pulled the Incredible Hulk into
that future from the past and so we had
two incredible hooks existing at the
same time we had the future virgin
maestro and we had the past version who
was the good Hulk basically the one who
who hadn't succumbed any kind of
dictatorial standard on how he ruled or
anything and the two of them ultimately
came into conflict and the story
continued on the way it normally would
but this one at this this Universal I'm
sorry this reality seems to be confined
to what's what appears to be the Society
of hulks and this is going to basically
be a land whereby we see a multitude of
iterations of the Incredible Hulk we're
going to see maestro we're going to see
The Incredible Hulk from maybe old man
Logan if they choose to bring him back
although that one's currently dead we're
going to see all these different
versions of The Incredible Hulk from all
across realities then we're going to see
them confined into a single location now
this is most likely going to be a story
that will launch after the definitely
conclusion of various other alternate
reality stories where they try to find
where all these incredible hoaxes are
going to go it seems as though they're
simply going to land and this one
particular location now the next one is
tecnópolis and Technopolis is based on
the armor wars
now this looks like it's going to take a
different take or a look it's going to
have a different take from the original
armored war storyline
of course the original armored war story
line that was a storyline whereby the
blueprints for Tony Stark's armor had
been stolen and they were being sold off
by Justin Hammer now eventually Tony
Stark was able to gain these things back
with the with the assistance of of Scott
Lang but what it looks like here is that
Tony Stark's not going to be successful
in getting his armor back and so the
question is going to be what's this
reality going to look like when Tony
Stark never got his armor back when
Justin Hammer continued to sell the
armor off to various people to various
countries and they develop their own
Iron Man armor now the next one is the
Regency and the Regency is the one that
I think has a lot of spider-man fans
entry to the reason why is because this
is actually an amalgamation of two
things one of the biggest catastrophes
in the history of spider-man comics was
the one more day event during the one
more day event this was a follow up to
Civil War and again this story was
followed up by a brand-new day but what
this did is it basically said created a
circumstance whereby no one remembered
that spider-man had revealed his
identity during the Civil War storyline
but more so than that the entire
marriage the entire existence I guess
between between spider-man and Mary J
Watson was completely cut clean and so
what it looks like Marvel's going to do
here is they're going to nullify one
more day they're going to retcon a
retcon
and so what they're going to say is that
after amazing spider-man annual issue
number 21 when Mary Jane Watson and
spider-man got married that this reality
is we want to continue on this reality
is basically going to be a reality
whereby one more day never happened and
so we're going to see what the world
looks like when spider-man and Mary Jay
want some state and married now the next
one is King James England and King James
King James England's going to bring us
Marvel 1602 it's going to reinstate the
Marvel 1602 universe now those of you
who were fans of the Marvel 1602 verse I
think you're going to love this and the
reason why is because as you know with
the Marvel 1602 universe this was a
universe where superheroes had appeared
four hundred years before they normally
would before instead of appearing in the
20th century they appear all the way
back in the end 1602 and so as a result
what we found was that there were a
multitude of things at work
ultimately from watching The Watcher as
well as Doctor Strange that there was an
event there was a forerunner that showed
up and so on and so forth things got
kind of hazy but as a result we
eventually found that the superheroes
that were emerging were not actually
supposed to emerge then the Marvel is
bringing this continuity back not only
that instead of us simply just seeing
these this alternate reality I guess
this this historical version this
alternate historical version of various
superheroes we're actually going to see
the Young Avengers show up here and so
Marvel simply appears to be expanding or
bolstering the ranks of the superheroes
who were who were appearing during the
1602 continuity now the next one is
x-men an x-men I think is a really big
one and the reason why is because this
story is going to I guess this reality
is going to be based off an amalgamation
of a couple different things the first
thing is going to be based off of is Jim
Lee and Chris Claremont run of the x-men
that is to say x-men 91 which is the
highest selling comic book of all time
but it looks like what is what it's
largely going to be based on its x-men
the animated series now again we know
that x-men the animated series was
largely based on Chris Claremont and Jim
Lee's run of the x-men but it was also
based on x-factor and so what it looks
like here is they're going to be
removing that x-factor element or at the
very least they're going to be telling
us what happens after x-men the animated
series came to an end
what does that version of the x-men like
now do they run into the Avengers and
this continuity of interest even exists
in this continuity because remember with
x-men the animated series we never saw
any of the Avengers or anything we never
saw any of the of the Fantastic Four we
didn't really see any of that stuff it
was simply isolated to the x-men there
was only one other real superhero that
we saw that wasn't part of the of the
x-men universe and that was black
panther we saw him one time it was
simply one flame and his back was to the
screen I don't know why God's name I
remember that but I do but the fact
remains this for those of you guys who
read DC Comics this x-men 92 is going to
be very similar to Batman 66 so that
makes any sense to you guys with that
being said I hope that made sense to you
guys I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from come
explain and talk to me directly